[موسيقى]
إنهم يعملون كثيرًا جدًا في عيون الخريف
كثيرًا مما نفعله لتقليل متطلبات التوظيف
عندما تنظر إلى أعدادنا ،
فنحن ما يزيد قليلاً عن 2600 بحار ،
والفرق البصري [الموسيقى] هو الجزيرة
نفسها هي الجزيرة  أبعد وأصغر
مما يسمح بمزيد من الصيانة
ومصمم بشكل مثالي لزيادة
معدل طلعتنا يوميًا بنسبة تصل إلى 33 في المائة جيدًا ، إنه أمر
مثير للغاية ، لذا فهي فرصة فريدة
وامتياز
كان دائمًا امتيازًا للخدمة على أي حال ولكني
أعتبر  امتياز وكذلك
فريقي عن كونه أول من يصطدم
وقد واجهنا الكثير من التحديات
في التكنولوجيا لأنها جديدة جدًا
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] الأنظمة التي أعتقد أنها نظريًا هي مجرد
ظاهرة ومصممة من أجل  أداء طريقة معينة
الآن ، سيكون التحدي هو
الخروج للتأكد من أنهم يفيون بالفعل
بالعلامة وأنهم يسمحون لنا بالقيام بما
نحتاج إلى القيام به وهو وضع هذه
السفينة في طريق الأذى والاستمرار في القتال
[موسيقى]